tes dons sont gâchés à force de zoner
dans ce troupeau mais
j'ai des choses à faire maman a besoin
d'assistance il faut faire les courses
le ménage je peux pas passer ma vie à
m'enfermer dans des Sims
et pas réel
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que c'est réalité virtuelle
avancée
ce truc pour eux en échange d'un max de
fric
laisse-toi aller
ferme les yeux c'est bon
compte à rebours à partir de 10
[Musique]
vous êtes à Londres
mais 70 ans plus tard que ce que vous
estimez être le présent
[Musique]
j'avais l'impression d'y être dans ton
corps vous êtes dans un périphérique
faut piloter ce corps comme si c'était
le vôtre
[Musique]
je pensais que j'étais dans une semaine
ici comme chez vous quand on tombe on se
blesse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]